bonjour Damien cimal paysagiste donc
aujourd'hui je vais présenter la taille
d'Arbus donc on va partir sur le
durantacta c'est une variété d'Arbus
plein soleil donc avec une fleuraison en
été pour la taille je vais utiliser ce
type de
CIS donc selon la hauteur de la plante
on a
plusieurs modèles de CISA ici en hauteur
et celui-là pour les petits
arbuses conse avant d'utiliser une
cisaille de désinfecter cette cisaille
là avec de l' javel parce que à force de
tailler les différents variétés d'â on
peut nu à la plante c'estàdire ramener
des maladies et la PL va pas pouvoir
vivre quoi un peu dégripant dans les
joints et sinon avoir une petite lime ou
un quera pour pouvoir mieux affuter la
lame en
fait la taille ça va servir à donner une
forme à à la plante pour qu'il puisse se
développer et pour avoir une floraison
un peu plus réguli dans l'année comme on
est dans un climat tropical donc la
floraison il va se faire régulièrement
si on fait une bonne taille sur ce petit
Darb je vais aller sur les formes
cylindrique afin de pouvoir couper les
bourgeons et de séparer lestouffes en
fait c'est c'est de séparer les arbuses
afin qu'il puissent respirer normalement
et se développer un à un
tranquillement pour couper droit met le
cisail du côté normal et afin de pouvoir
tailler en rond ou cylindrique attaquer
le cisail à l'inverse à force de tailler
de tailler c'est c'est avec l'habitude
qu'on pourra trouver sa technique pour
pouvoir bien tailler ces arbustes là
coupe
droit on va couper juste les petits
bouons afin d'égaliser le tour et je
vais
arrondir la tête de l'arbus et là je
vais incliner la
cisaille donc moi me conseille à un
petite astuce hein en fait se décaler un
peu et regarder la forme de l'absce afin
de pouvoir détecter les Ty bougeons
qu'on n' pas pu tailler avec la
sisail ben là je vais garder les arbuses
de tous sa même forme et en fonction en
grandissant je vais modifier sa forme en
fonction de sa grandeur et en fonction
du massif aussi donc par exemple mettre
les les arbuses en hauteur qui sont
derrière plus haut et les petits bus qui
sont je vais les tailler plus petits qui
sont qui sont devant le
massif s'est trouvé son inspiration tout
seul en fait
donc écouter la nature et laisser le
cœur et l'esprit agir tout
simplement